on est aujourd'hui face à une crise qui
est immense et qui
c'est de l'humanité est dense
crise quelque chose qui m'est très
important et je pense qu'il faut qu'on y
pense c'est le développement le
développement de tous les pays pauvres
parce que à terme ce qui va se passer
c'est que on va se retrouver dans un
déséquilibre tels que ça va générer des
conflits qui vont venir nous toucher
dans le coeur de nos sociétés la
répartition des richesse globale à
travers tout le globe est une nécessité
aujourd'hui on est très accaparé par une
crise qui est celle de l'écologie
d'accord mais à mon avis il va se
trouver un moment où l'environnement va
s'adapter pas faire son chemin un autre
dépend à nous les hommes iront des
planchers cette crise quelque part à
cause de nos activités mais au final
qu'est ce qui va se produire pour nous
des êtres humains
comment allons nous nous comporter
lorsqu'on sera face à une crise si aigu
que ça sera une question de survie
alors il est très simple d'imaginer ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'on va déjà
perdre toutes nos valeurs d'humanisme
tous les fondamentaux qui nous ont
permis de construire des sociétés
civilisées d'aujourd'hui les peuples
vont commencer à se replier sur eux
mêmes et les nations et pays on prend
des postures des défenses et même de
combat pour protéger leurs acquis le
tableau je voudrais c'est assez sombre
mais franchement y'a pas besoin d'aller
bien loin suivi d'allumer nos
télévisions et on voit qu aux portes de
l'europe
les bateaux de migrants et ont fui la
misère et les guerres sont refoulés de
port en port on veut plus les accueillir
déjà des signes que l'on commence à se
protéger dans le nord de l'envahissement
des migrants on se dit où l'art
c'est tous des gens débarquent chez nous
ils vont nous ruiner c'est exactement le
discours qui est en train de se passer
donc l'environnement
d'accord il va y avoir un effondrement
écologique mais tôt ou tard elle va se
débrouiller sans nous d'où la nécessité
de prendre en compte aujourd'hui le
développement des pays pauvres
de sorte à ce que l'on sorte de ce
déséquilibre
on est dans une crise qui paradoxalement
grâce à la médiatisation nous pour faire
prendre conscience par exemple de ce qui
se passe en afrique
les projecteurs sont sur l'afrique et
les crises et dont on commence à se
rendre compte des risques potentiels
pour nos sociétés aujourd'hui ici où
l'on se sent bien ou dans le confort
mais je suis un optimiste et je sais que
c'est en temps de crise que les
opportunités de développement sont les
plus importants c'est vrai quand on a
des crises on se réveille on s'agite on
pense différemment on cherche des
solutions
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
se produire
c'est la chance pour l'afrique de
rebattre les cartes du jeu du jeu
international c'est la chance pour
l'afrique de dire aux pays du nord les
occidentaux de dire ok ça a toujours
fonctionné comme ça mais ce qu'on peut
pas fonctionner autrement c'est le
moment idéal parce qu'on est en temps de
crise le crise pour le nord et pour le
sud et crise dans les relations entre
les deux et ceux ci mais cet optimiste
vision des choses se produit dans un
contexte assez dramatique
en afrique on a toutes ces mouvements
protestataires qui réclament la
démocratie avec la violence avec du sang
on a les yeux a dit ce qui commence à
rentrer qu'ils font qui fonda une
massacre dans leurs incursions on a les
bateaux de migrants on a toutes les
forces vives de la jeunesse africaine
qui s'en vont qui traversent le sahara
la méditerranée et kick et qui meurt par
masse
sur site sur ce chemin en espérant plus
de bonheur en occident mais je suis
convaincu que si l'on prend les choses
autrement on peut y arriver on peut
développer les pays pour pour qu'ils
atteignent des niveaux de vie qui n'est
même plus en danger ni nous ni la
globalité de l'humanité je suis vraiment
convaincu de sa l'occident les pays
européens ont fait leur première
rencontre avec les africains environ 16h
17m sept de ces rencontres il s'est
passé des bouleversements en afrique des
modèles étrangers sont venus se sont
implantées dans les cultures les
traditions les dynamiques africaine et
qui ont créé des ruptures dans la
dynamique africaine aujourd'hui on est
encore dans une espèce de logique qui
est dirigiste
l'europe veut se donner bonne conscience
en se disant qu'elle doit aider les pays
africains à se développer pour ça elles
ont mis en place des systèmes qu'on
appelle l'aide au développement qui à
mon avis est une grosse arnaque et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi et des
développements c'est un outil
d'influencé pour les pays pour les
puissances du nord
c'est un outil idéologique on se
prévaloir d'une bonne conscience en se
disant on les ailes et pays qui ne sont
pas capables de cdn
mais n'empêche que cette aide masquer
des chiffres extrêmement importants qui
sont ceux du flux des capitaux entre le
nord et le sud et le sud et le nord il
ya eu en europe un rapport qui a été
émis en 2016 sur la base des chiffres de
2012 lorsque les pays dits avancés
donnait de l'argent aux pays pauvres à
hauteur de 1,3 milliard de dollars dans
la même année
3.3 milliards de dollars se déplaçait du
sud vers les pays du nord
au final ce qui se passe c'est que les
pays pauvres qui sont censés être aider
à se développer ont financé le
développement l'économie des pays du
nord à raison de deux 2 2 2 milliards à
peu près donc c'est un paradis qui ne
peut pas fonctionner si l'on veut que
les choses changent on doit penser
autrement
on doit se voir autrement doit voir le
monde autrement et faire naître des
paradigmes différents et c'est là que
mon discours arrive c'est de dire que
nous tous qui sommes ici les nouveaux
leaders d'opinion les jeunes
entrepreneurs les étudiants les
travailleurs les migrants on doit mettre
en place on doit utiliser la chance que
nous avons la chance de pouvoir
dialoguer entre les générations pour
mettre en place une nouvelle façon de
voir le monde et de mettre en place une
nouvelle approche du développement
je suis convaincu que la discussion
entre les générations vont permettre à
cette nouvelle génération de déployer
une intelligence aiguë du contexte
international du jeu international et je
pense que l'on peut mettre en place un
nouveau paradigme qui est basée sur la
collecte sur la réorganisation sur le
fait de donner du sens à l'information
au savoir
nous avons ici dans le nord accumulé
tant de savoir tant de savoir faire que
si l'on est capable de le travailler de
travail et 7,1 sur informations de façon
utile et de l'adapter à la dynamique des
pays en voie de développement des pays
pauvres
je ne parle pas que pour l'afrique il
serait capable on serait capable de
dynamiser de faire un bond quantique
dans le développement de ces pays
mais pour cela il faut en mettre en
place cette nouveau paradigme
ce que j'entends par nouveau paradigme
c'est vraiment cette idée de transférer
les ressources de savoir le savoir-faire
de technologies qui se sont accumulées
dans le nord et les déplacer vers les
pays pauvres les pays en voie de
développement pour y créer une valeur
ajoutée sur place et orienter ce
développement sur place nous éviter
toute la captation tout le transfert de
capitaux qui vont aller vers le nord
pour que ces pays puissent se développer
nous avons en afrique un potentiel
énorme des rapports font t on des
rapports des derniers rapports font état
de 5 % de croissance annuelle depuis dix
ans en afrique le continent est
extrêmement jeune 18 ans de moyenne
d'âge
il ya des pays où il ya plus de 70 % de
jeunes de moins de 18 ans l'expansion de
la population est énorme
rien qu'en afrique de l'ouest dans les
trente prochaines années on se
retrouvera avec plus de 1 milliard de
personnes il y à un développement énorme
qui se fait au niveau de la classe
moyenne qui est en train de croître et
qui va générer toute une dynamique les
réseaux commerciaux intercontinental
interne régional sont pauvres 17%
il ya donc un potentiel énorme de
développement il va falloir pouvoir
utiliser ce potentiel de développement
selon un autre paradigme de
développement
ce paradigme de développement il est
basé sur le fait comme je voulais dit
d'utiliser les ressources du nord en
tant en terme de savoir de connaissances
de savoirs faire de technologie de
mettre en place ici des communautés
générationnel qui vont pouvoir
travailler et utiliser tout ce savoir et
développer les pays pauvres selon leur
propre dynamique et selon leur propre
culture quitte
à être en de ground pas dire qui tu as à
passer sous les radars des gouvernements
puisqu'on peut plus trop leur faire
confiance en afrique en tout cas à créer
des réseaux à être collaboratif à être
participatif créé des associations créer
des partenariats
nous avons en occident des entreprises
qui ont un savoir faire mais qui ne
connaissent pas le marché africain
alors que nous avons des entrepreneurs
africains qui eux ont la maîtrise
technologique la connaissance du marché
emea qui manque le partenariat et
l'expertisé des expertises nécessaires
pour développer pour aller plus loin
pour aller au delà de leur marché donc
si l'on est capable de créer ce nouveau
paradigme des d'influer cette
transformation sera capable j'en suis
certain de développer les pays pauvres
comme ceux de l'afrique et c'est une
nécessité c'est une réalité qui s'impose
à nous et si on ne le fait pas je pense
que l'opéra tous tous les conséquences
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]